[Musique]
voir les enfants
aux faucons le bien sur notre petit
nuage
pas trop ce soir je me repose
tu ne descend pas voir tes amis l'ont
ils sont trop qu'aucun
halo
nounours à la parole est à mme non non y
attaquer pour toi impôts pack est
ce vrai et tu serais content qu'il
vienne si j'ai le temps je suis très
occupé j'ai bien
commencé
je suis bien très haut non ne soyez pas
triste je vais réfléchir nul à
raccrocher ne fait pas l'air quoi car
notre groupe mais peut-être parce qu'on
lui après toutes ces pièces d'argent
hier et il sait pas convaincu groupe je
peux entrer je le fais copas
oui merci vous va très bien merci
regarde sur la table
c'est vous pas qu il est peut-être c'est
sûrement une farce au nom regarde quel
temps voyons au dessous pour ce gentil
toutes mes économies
des économies des neuneus merci les
enfants meurent sur j'aime bien tcc pas
tout assieds toi on va gâter et fana
du
jeu que je suis gratuit hier et pour
notre nounou et là y'a un casino
mois ci la fin de la journée
fait le moment de se coucher
nous jeter encore nos amis qui les 112
au lit
nous y allons en fait
sans nuage j'en suis certain le marchand
de sable vient
il nous dira
mais vos yeux est d'emmener tous les
deux
[Musique]
nous sommes bien dans notre lit none of
fouettard nuit sa grosse voix m'a fait
plaisir quand je vais m'endormir
je vais m'endormir
ça va nous faire plaisir
[Musique]
vous êtes de vrais petits anges je suis
le plus heureux des nounours
jette à la lumière
deux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
gros lolos le beau rôle all bat oloron
on n'y va pas trop oui en route nounours
le vieux veulent vous ne trouvez pro
très belle mon bon nounours bonne nuit
les enfants fait pour eux
[Musique]
oh